we're speaking today with Heidi sure
holds the chief economist's at the US
Department of Labor Heidi follows the
job trends and occupational
opportunities around the country and so
this is a good opportunity to discuss
where some of the good jobs are so Heidi
thank you for joining us today it's my
pleasure wonder if you could start by
telling us what do you see is some of
the good job opportunities for young
people entering the labor force today I
think it's important to know that there
are a lot of good jobs being created
there are a lot of good opportunities
and if you look our bureau of labor
statistics does these employment
projections or you can look and see what
kind of jobs are growing strongly for
the next ten years what kind of wages
will those jobs have and there's some
trends that come out of that that you
can see so some of the fastest growing
jobs are jobs in the health sector
particularly nurses really strong range
is a really strong job growth we also
see good job growth in the tech sector
so software engineering software
development those kinds of jobs are
growing quickly you also see projected
growth in some jobs and professional and
business services like accountant jobs
and auditing jobs sort of those old
standbys we're gonna always need them
and they're really decent paying jobs so
that's at the high end of the labor
force how about at the middle tier of
the labor force what's happening there
one of the phenomenons that we're seeing
there is there's this big group of
people who are hitting retirement age
the baby boomers and as that continues
to happen there's gonna be a lot of job
turnover in some of these really good
middle-class jobs like carpenter jobs
electrician jobs utility workers up
welders those kinds of jobs that
historically people got a lot of
training in those kind of jobs through
their unions and apprenticeship programs
as we have the this group of people that
was trained in that way hitting
retirement age we have to really figure
out how we're going to refill those jobs
one of the things the Department of
Labor is doing is really doing
everything we can to support a
partnership
programs they can help train up people
to get into those jobs to those are
really good middle-class jobs that are
gonna be very in-demand going forward
well that's great because
apprenticeships have such a positive
record so rebuilding those is so
critical to our economy and the future
workforce research shows apprenticeship
has the highest rate of return as far as
investment in workers what pays off for
the economy for their future earnings so
it's a really good it's a really good
route for our country to invest in him
for people to take advantage of as
they're thinking about what their
careers are gonna look like going
forward and what about at the lower end
of the occupational distribution the
projections show that we're expected to
add a lot of jobs that at this point are
low wage jobs home health aides food
prep workers and restaurants and bars
childcare workers janitors maids and
housekeeping cleaners so some of these
lower end jobs are projected to see
strong growth going forward so what I
think that's a really important segment
of the labor market to think about and
that's where policy can come in to help
make sure that those are better jobs so
things like making sure we have a decent
minimum wage increasing the minimum wage
making sure people have overtime
protections making sure that people have
paid leave the president just announced
initiatives to bolster paid leave in the
United States those kinds of policies
can help ensure that even jobs that we
have high quality jobs for people at all
levels of education and training
certainly important that we really help
to improve those low-wage jobs and
provide career opportunities for growth
and so on what else would you say that
young people need to do to prepare for
the good jobs of the future thinking
about investments in your own training
and education over the course of your
career is just a really smart idea um
one of the things people should be doing
is asking their employers for what
opportunities there are for advancement
asking your Union what can you do to
help help support these kind of
your letters looking into things like
joint Union and management programs that
support these kind of career letters for
example there's there's programs that
will help people go from a nursing
assistant to an LPN to a registered
nurse and if you can think of supporting
those kinds of trajectories you can
really carve out a career that really
let's let you punch punch the ticket to
the middle class I think that's that's
good advice young people have lots of
opportunities and they have to create
new ones along with the partnership of
the Department of Labor and good
employers and good labor organizations
so thank you very much it's been my
pleasure
[Music]